a lot of people say that the world will
be darker and there is no truth anymore
and the haers will win I think that the
next couple of years will be difficult
because the attackers are early adopters
they are much faster in adopting this
new technologies than the Defenders but
in the long run there is much more
implications for the cyber security then
is this for the attackers
[Laughter]
[Music]
Bobby Gilbert welcome to 20 minute
leaders I've been waiting so long for
this episode and our conversation thank
you so much for joining me from the
teammate offices thank you for having me
and I'm really excited about this
opportunity to talk with you and to take
part in this amazing podcast it's it's
it's gon to be great because Bobby you
know this this whole show is really
about curiosity passion you know where
do we dedicate our time and energy the
the journey that you that you're on and
that you've had is is you know it's a
it's really something that I think I I I
I definitely want to dive into and and
share here because it's non-traditional
it it's extremely Innovative and I think
it speaks a lot to every conversation
that we we have and we've had a couple
now on on the context of cyber security
and AI I can just see the the interest
and passion coming out of you so so I
want to bring that to light here so let
we'll get started but but Bobby tell me
a little bit about your name because you
threw something at me right before we
started that there's interesting stories
behind both names tell me about it yes
so so the the the first name is Bobby
actually the name on the ID card is B
which means blessed in the in Hebrew but
as soon as I was brought back from the
hospital my older
sister she is about uh one year older
than me this is how she pronounced my
name and it taks since then since day
zero or the 10 of my life so Bobby is is
the the name this is how she called me
this is how my parents called me and
this is how everyone called me actually
the family name is Marciano Gilbert
because I'm married to to Marciano AB is
a doctor in communication and life
science in boron University and this is
the other part my my name this is a long
name and they pronounce it the way that
they like it I love it Bobby tell me
little bit about about your your journey
it's a not not a traditional Journey but
but it's one that that exemplifies
excellence and curiosity so what what
have been really the big milestones in
your mind okay so I I I I I think that
I'm currently in the second phase the
first phase of my professional career
was in in the army unit 8200 I've
graduated 26 years of service I've
joined the age of 18 and I was part of U
the IDF unit
200 up until the age of 44 I retired as
colonal I feel really lucky because I
had the opportunity to
do amazing things everything that you
see in the movies about cyber hacking
Etc multiply it by thousand and this was
my day to day I like to say that I was
happy with a license and they had the
opportunity to do amazing things for the
first time but I'm sure that uh in the
next 20 30 40 years history will be
history books will be written about what
we need what Israel did back then and I
feel really lucky to had the opportunity
to take part in this you're you so you
spent 26 years in this in in this now
now I I I got to spend five years so I I
understand the the the experience that
you have there but today in your role at
teammate you're running at the fastest
space possible you're looking you're
you're you're constantly shifting and
exploring what's up ahead and your and
speed and execution of the Forefront how
does and so I think a lot of people when
they think of military service it does
it's not necessarily a perfect fit for
this type of Personality yes what how
did it fit for you yeah so so the thing
that I like the best and the thing that
I think that I am best at has to do with
Innovation and looking for new
opportunities and this is exactly what
the intelligence Mission needs because
it's always about
looking what is not obvious and what we
can do that the other haven't thought
about so on the Army side we had the
enemy on on the the The Innovation side
in the and now on the the private sector
we trying to innovate those things that
others didn't think of
so the enemy was replaced by the the
contents they're trying to think of
things that others haven't and it's all
about innov in and building new things
building new Frameworks building new
groups and I think that I've learned a
lot back then about the technology and
about Innovation and about research I
actually led the research for this
amazing unit for a a couple of years and
uh when I've joined teammate nadab which
is one of the founders of a teammate he
called me um I forgot it he's not my
commander anymore and they said they
come join us and I said of course if
ifav so I will do this and the thing
that I'm doing today has a lot of
similarity to what I did take then
because it has to do with Innovation
about thinking of New
Opportunities and there is no better
time to innovate than in 2024
2025 I said that I was feeling lucky
back then at un 8200 to add opportunity
to do the things that we do I feel even
more lucky to be part of the ecosystem
that designed the take
industry today with the introduction of
this amazing alien technology into our
life the
AI is
about uh I think this is the mo this is
definitely the
most important technological Milestone
that every one of us will encounter In
Our Lifetime it's bigger than the cloud
it's bigger than the internet I think
the the the the best analogy can be the
the the printed press or the spoken
language this is amazing technology and
they feel lucky again to be part of of
er the community that tries to think
what we can do with this new new
toy which is exciting even more than the
second than the first part of my career
Bobby I we're going to get a whole lot
into um H the you know what's what we're
excited about up ahead and the with the
role of AI particularly in cyber
security but I want to take you back for
a second your experience is that leading
thousands of of a of innovators
researchers Engineers soldiers non-s
soldiers you've done it extremely
successfully and and one of the things
that I'm always very curious about is
what makes what's the difference between
you know very talented people who manag
to achieve excellent results and and
really talented people who don't right
in the startup scene we see that all the
time um and so what is your take now
that you've seen dozens of projects many
succeeded I'm sure that many didn't how
what is your Now sort of dision when you
see a talented group of people what are
really the fundamental things that you
believe in that will help them achieve
good results okay I I'll I'll say two
things one is leadership and the second
is is uh avoiding fear I'll start with
the second one the thing that we like
that we like to do in unit 8200 was to
take young H recruits and people are
joining at the age of 18 this is the
first professional challenge in their
lifetime this is the first workplace and
uh from time to time we take problems
that a lot of people with a lot of money
try to Sol before them and they are just
not aware of the the past experience
past failures in solving this problem
and we asked them to solve them to solve
this problem and from time to
time we were really surprised that
people actually managed to solve this
problem that were not able to uh so pre
um 10 or 20 years before and the reason
that they haven't failed in this mission
is that they avoided ER fear they were
not feared of failor and this is one
thing the second is the leadership is by
way the you know I remember distinctly
the second week of my course I did Myas
and my second week of my course I come
into the room I don't know if I can
share this but but I come into the room
and and we don't have a mouse just have
keyboards yeah yeah this is a known
practice and we're sitting there and
you're talking about fear so there's
many types of fears trust me when you're
sitting for 3 hours trying to log in to
Windows without a mouse and don't know
how to select and you're figuring out
the
combination it's a fear that you have to
fear yeah yeah this this is a non
practice and it's become even more
vicious
nowaday we have some new we have some
new tricks since your day and then yeah
yeah but this is all about not fearing
and and and and and understanding that
they actually can do
everything and as people grow they
collect more fears with them and they
avoid U try avoiding trying to solve
problems that other ER have failed H so
if you are young you you don't have this
fear I seen it for my kids today and
this is the reason that they are hard
themselves so much but when it come to
Innovation and research avoiding the
theories against him the second is is
the leadership of course taking this
talent
and being able to direct it to the right
direction
and I I I I will share with you
one maybe not so known
Secrets uh there haven't been a lot of
good things in the IDF from taking H
Colonels or even captains in a room they
don't do anything they just create
problems The Innovation comes from the
young people from the bottom up and
Leadership is all about allowing these
young
innovators and don't stop and oh we
don't need this or go back to your
work actually when you're leading
Innovation you can command someone to be
Innovative I command you to find the
solution for this problem no you you and
and and and this is the usual Army
practice but it has nothing to do with
the Innovation and research and it's all
about connecting them to the mission in
the case of the IDF it's really easy
because the mission is the security of
their family
in the case of the private sector is
more difficult but again it's about
creating many money or or or success in
whether whe kpi but from time to time
people just don't make this connection
of how will solving this problem create
me achieving this higher goal or
strategy and this the leadership is
taking there and say okay if you solve
this if we Sol it as a all and then this
will be the implication it can be on the
national level it can be Global
implications and these are do to compan
talented people talented group with the
right leadership can do anything
anything there is no any asri here there
is no any small letters here young
people talented people sorry with the
right leadership can solve any problem
and the think that we lack the most now
my second part of in in unit 82 100
actually we were chasing ideas and we
were chasing ideas because we had the
talent to implement them I think one of
the major surprises for
me after joining the private sector and
teammate is that it's not about ideas
anymore it's about Talent so in the
private sector in the real world we are
chasing
Talent there are a lot of ideas that
best way to be picked from the the the
floor but it's all about the talent that
can do the
execution of this in execution it's not
only the technology these are the sales
and the products and everything that we
already know so this is a major
difference between what they did in the
Army and what they am doing right now
back then I would chasing good ideas now
we are chasing mainly good people we had
a lot of ideas but we're looking for the
right things
to pick these dreams and Implement them
right but I think that what you did with
teammate is that you've created a a sort
of an ecosystem which has the two levels
right you have the you've you've
generated perhaps the the most in
incredible and important group of of
Industry experts that represent the the
state of cyber security from a Solutions
perspective an implementers perspective
and you're and you have on the other
hand you know if you just look at the
portfolio of T obviously you're you're
backing the most talented entrepreneurs
that and then you you create that
platform for for solution oriented
results right I completely agree with
you and then we'll add another
compliment component and this is the
village the village of Security leaders
we cannot do what we do without this we
are not thinking about any idea on our
own this is the way that we communicate
with the reality is by communicating
with group and the leadership uh that I
was talking about in un a is the
leadership in leading this her of
Security leaders and understanding their
real pains and trying to solve the right
problems with the right Solutions so uh
yes this is the the experts that we have
here it's connecting the ecosystem and
the problem and of
course being grounded to Earth through
this amazing community of Security
leaders that we are have you and
connecting with this component this is
the secret absolutely let's let's do a a
shift for a second to this intersection
of of of AI and cyber security from your
point of view you know we're in we're in
May 1st of
2024 um we we we're starting to
understand the implications of AI you
said it beautifully that this is perhaps
the most important and catalytic
technology from ever you know that's
equatable to the as much as as the
language itself I fully agree with right
the language itself fully agree with you
not the Industrial Revolution not the
nuclear weaponry this is a fundamental
shift in in how the human brain is going
to experience reality um what's going to
happen over the next two three years do
you think in the cyber security space
where are the big building blocks
opportunities yeah
uh so I I will start from the end I'm
optimistic the reason that I'm saying
this is that a lot of people say that
the world will be darker and there is no
truth anymore and the haers will win I
think that the next couple of years will
be difficult because the attackers are
early adopters and they are much faster
in adopting these new technologies and
the Defenders and we are seeing it
already we are seeing it with automated
attacks we are seeing it with the
generated content video and audio we're
seeing it with the automated tools and
using GPT in order to understand what
the patches are all about and creating
the exploit faster than the people are
installing the patches but in the long
run in the long run there is much more
implications for the cyber security ER W
then is this for the attackers and
um actually I think that we used to say
that the attacker and Defender ecosystem
is
a inherently asymmetric and for for the
attacker to win they should only find
one one hole and for the defender to do
their work they
should look all around
where all the time I think AI actually
has the opportunity to break this
inherent ER
inequality and make the Defenders for
the first time the same level with the
attackers because they can guard
everywhere anytime using this automated
technology so in the long run I think
cyber security will benefit much more
than from these Technologies than the
attackers will and the world will be
more cyber
secure ER but the the in the following
two three even four years this is going
to be tough because a lot of people
that have the lot of
organization I think that if you were
cyber cyber negligent if your
organization was was in just a too low
level of face security it was probably
already been wiped and attack but
organization that are not C in the Cyber
negligence level and they're not high
valued targets ER just we're not Target
of attack this will change because now
the spray and
prey is done in
magnitudes that we haven't seen anymore
everyone will be exploited and it will
take not days but minutes and
seconds so everyone should be ready for
this but in the long
run we will be able to fight fake much
better than we can create fake we will
be able to detect
fishing and stop attacks much more much
faster than we can create attacks and
I'm optimistic but again this
create new CH this create an challenges
and on top of this these are new
challenges for example securing AI
systems this is something new AI is a
target for attackers not as a tool for
attackers
in but SEC not use using AI for security
but securing AI this is something new
this is a new component that was not
there yet this is the thing that I'm
currently most passionate about this is
the thing that I'm currently leading a
teammate and this is the thing that I'm
taking with me from my past career
because back then we asked ourselves
whether we can do confidential work in
the public cloud and the answer back
back then was no we cannot do because we
cannot secure our in confidential Ai and
this is a challenge that strikes me
strikes me then and followed me uh since
then how can you do large scale AI on
public
infrastructure ER while maintaining the
security confidentiality of the model
the training data Etc so securing AI not
AI for security this is something new
and this is one of the things that is
we are currently putting most more focus
on in teammate I actually believe that
we we teamate will be do something
around this in the next year or so we
see a lot of opportunities there this is
both for the consumers of AI the users
of the gpts and the the the co-pilots
but even more for the creators of
applications and models they should make
sure that they're uh
models and application are pro are
protected from these kinds of attacks we
haven't seen these attacks on the wild
yet but I think this is a matter of days
weeks or even
years but but not years before we will
see one major AI attack I think we are
now in the stage of it's like op
security before stet no one was talking
about OT security before stet and then
we have this one event that changed
everything think we will have the stack
net of the
AI I believe it will be happen in the
next year if not earlier and then
everyone will
be asking themselves how we how can I
protect my organization from the
this adversarial attack so this is
something new the think that are
currently we are currently invested in
uh looking around for the technology
opportunity it is what is there for the
third parties and what is there for the
vendors because this is also a question
the vendors cannot leave this world
unsecure okay so if Microsoft are so
invested in GPT and AI they cannot leave
it for third parties so we ask ourselves
what is there left that is left for
third parties and will not be covered by
the large weathers and this is I thing
that I can talk for hours actually we
have we are after I think almost 200
validation calls around this and we have
good understanding of this this Arena
right now incredible Bobby so I mean
first of all from the optimism you know
this the world will be more cyber secure
this is a fundamental yeah um I idea
that I very very much resonate with and
I fully agree and I think that it's a
great um it's it's a it's an amazing
it's amazing light to have the out of
the tunnel and then but understanding
that the next few years will be
interesting we we'll see events unfold
particularly interesting the distinction
that of securing not only using AI to
secure but securing AI I think that it
requires a whole different deep
conversation to dive into that which I
would love to have and but then also
this idea that you know if until now
really high value targets were the ones
being attacked because of the difficulty
to attack this and pre which becomes
much more accessible and much more
opportunistic everyone is now with
Target yeah everybody's now and uh and
you know that that also has I you know
I'm thinking back to what we do with
with deep fakes I think that that's an a
big a big understanding that it's not
just the large Enterprises necessarily
that need layers of protection and I
think this Insight is is very likely
highly relevant to many stakeholders and
and so Bobby first of all I want to I
want to thank you for for for being here
here and um what a what a journey and uh
and I think that this is certainly you
know I've done I think over a thousand
of these conversations but know but I
have to very authentically share that
this was one of my favorite ones ER and
and and your your optimism and your
curiosity and excitement just runs
through the screen so thank you for that
and uh best of luck with everything you
do I'm excited to keep in touch thank
you it was fun thank you very much thank
you so much